[Music]
part of what i enjoy about
your
mind and commentary is that it spans the
spans from the macro to the intensely
personal so i'm going to come back to
buffett monger but i'm going to take a
detour for a moment less people think
we're going to get too into the weeds on
on banks for the next hour which we
might get into a bit more of it but i
want to go to a piece that you wrote
some time ago
and this is financial advice for my new
son
you wrote this
october 13th or you published it october
13th 2015 so that's let's just call it
six years ago a bit over six years ago
and your son had been born the week
before and you listed out
a number of different
i wouldn't say rules but
bits of financial advice and one one
that stuck out to me that i particularly
enjoyed i'm just going to read it here
because it's it's it's one of those
things again that is
obvious once you've heard it obvious in
retrospect but the framing
is very
helpful and i hadn't read it presented
in just this way so number one you might
think you want an expensive car a fancy
watch in a huge house but i'm telling
you you don't what you want is respect
and admiration from other people and you
think having expensive stuff will bring
it it almost never does especially from
the people you want to respect and
admire you
here's the paragraph that stuck out to
me when you see someone driving a nice
car you probably don't think wow that
person is cool instead you think wow if
i had that car people would think i'm
cool do you see the irony no one cares
about the guy in the car have fun buy
some nice stuff but realize that what
people are really after is respect and
humility will ultimately gain you more
of it than vanity now the the last
sentence
has some counter examples maybe yes but
the
point that we rarely look at the person
in the cool car and say wow that person
must be cool rather we apply it to
ourselves is i think a very profound
observation
what would you add to this list and
people can certainly find this we'll
link to in the show notes people can
find it easily but
is there anything you would add to this
list now six years later or that you
would
change in any material way
well first let me let me give some
insight into that man-in-the-car paradox
as i call it i when i was in college i
was a valet at a high-end hotel in los
angeles so i was in my early 20s and
there were people coming in and ferraris
and lamborghinis and rolls royces like
the whole the whole thing
and it dawned on me one day that when
those cars pulled in that i had really
admired i'm a car guy i'd love that
never once did i look at the driver and
say that guy's cool what i did is i
imagined myself as a driver and i
thought people would think i'm cool and
this was like i was in my early 20s but
i was thinking like this that was my
first kind of light bulb into how wealth
works that everyone thinks that they
want to be the driver but no one
actually is paying attention to the
driver they're imagining themselves
people think about themselves way more
than they think about other people and
but we all think that everyone's looking
at us i think that's like a universal
thing everyone thinks like oh this
person is looking at me they're
impressed with me by and large they're
not they're thinking about themselves
and how other people might want to be
impressed with them
so that was some some insight into that
view what i would add today now that my
son is six and we have a two-year-old
daughter as well and i think i knew this
before becoming a parent but until
you're a parent it's just hard to fathom
how powerful it is it's just you have no
clue
who your kids are gonna grow up to be
and i saw this especially when my
daughter was born and now that my
daughter is two they they are so
different from one another my son and
daughter completely different despite
growing up with the same parents in the
same house with the same means
everything they could not be more night
and day now of course they're four years
apart and they're different genders of
course but they it's the personality
differences are so stark and that just
makes me think like whenever you want a
picture or imagine who your kids
might be someday it's like you have no
clue what they're going to grow up to be
i think that it's intuitive to think
that my kids will grow up similar to my
wife and i because i'm going to instill
in them the values that my wife and i
value
but they're like they're so starkly
different from one another and i'm so
different from my brother and sister we
went so completely different ways in
life that it's it's so hard to give your
kids advice when they're young when you
have no clue where they're going to end
up so people have asked me this question
similar to you know on on going off of
that article
what would i teach them now or or or how
am i teaching my my son about money now
that he's old enough to start to get the
basics of it and the truth is i'm really
not because i don't know maybe when he's
a young adult he wants to be a partner
at goldman sachs maybe he wants to work
for greenpeace like who knows what he's
going to be and therefore i can't give
him or anyone universal financial advice
and say this is what you should do this
is what you should value this is where
you should go because we're all so
incredibly different in our goals and
our talents and our aspirations
you